You don't need a facelift,
you don't need a nose job and you don't need filler.
You're just getting a little older and losing collagen in your face.
And trust me, at 34,
I was not liking what I was seeing in the mirror.
I was seriously on the fence about getting some work done
because once the eyes start hollowing,
the smile line start folding over,
pressure to throw a bunch of money and needles at the med
spa is really strong. To be honest,
my skincare routine was all over the place.
I was just walking into Sephora
and buying whatever
random products that skin influencers were posting about.
But then I saw real women,
not skin influencers, showing their real before and afters
and giving real reviews of this Korean anti aging system.
And each one of these products are formulated to work together
to bring the volume back into your skin.
I've been using this morning and night for the past six months.
And this is me at 35. No filler,
no talk, no makeup.
And correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think I look 10 years younger.
I finally
feel like I can walk out of the house without piling on concealer.
Actually excited to do my skincare routine now
because it's actually doing something
and I'm seeing real changes
because I don't know how many products I've bought
where it says it's gonna do something
and it doesn't do Jack.
But this is The first time I've used Korean skincare
and I think they are just light years ahead of us
when it comes to formulations and ingredients.
They said to start out with the pink speckle serum.
They're calling this micro needling in a bottle
because these tiny
microscopic spicules are going to stimulate your skin
and shed dead skin, give you a big boost of collagen.
This is what shrank my giant bucket pores
and smoothed out my skin texture
and stop my makeup from looking like this.
I'm telling you, the redness,
the hyperpigmentation, the sun spots,
the old acne marks
are the reason why you feel like you need to wear foundation
all the time. This is a melanin inhibitor.
So not only is it fading existing dark marks and redness,
helping to stop new pigmentation from forming.
So even if I do get a pimple,
it's not scarring or lingering for two years.
Over consistent use, it faded all of my old acne marks,
brightened up that redness and gave me that Korean glass skin glow.
So we're smoothing, then we're brightening,
and now we're firming. This is the Calcium Volume Cream,
which has 10,000 ppms of an ingredient that Dr Melaxin patented
called reborn in Calcium.
And Calcium is the precursor to boosting collagen,
is a firming cream.
So it will have that tight top feeling once it dries down.
But that's what we want.
They're saying they're waking up with frozen foreheads,
which I am not. Mad about because although I still have movement
those fine lines are gone baby gone
make sure you bring this all the way down to your neck
to tighten up any creeping and sagging skin
and the mega viral Calcium core stick that broke the internet
we're calling this the Korean Botox stick
and it's because of the ingredients
has that same reborn a Calcium
plus adenosine and glutathione is a powerhouse combo for smoothing,
hydrating and plumping up loss volume
then you're gonna layer on the juiciest facial patches
which are soaked in that same reborn a Calcium and collagen
you gotta make sure you're putting them on the nasal labial folds too.
Wear these for at least 15 minutes
or I go to sleep with them on
so I can really soak up all that anti wrinkle juice
they'll solidify they're not gonna budge
and I always wake up looking like I slept 12 hours
I'm gonna die on this hill
but these two products completely got rid of my under eye bags
and my smile lines my friends are sick of me talking about this
so I made friends with the ladies in my comments
and we're all on the same page
that Korean skincare is it.
There were some women in the reviews that were pissed
that they had to wait over a month to be able to order this
because it kept selling out
there's a flash sale that was 75% off
and they completely Sold out the whole stock.
I'm gonna link it for you so you can read the reviews.
But if the link isn't there,
then it's sold out. And I'm sorry.